or all the sections of their analysis
today we'll be working with four
sections the RNA seek section and dam I
supervised analysis section unsupervised
analysis section and intelligence
section and all the sections have
similar interface so let's go to a seek
section to get a handle how to paint for
pipelines first was where us to do is to
fill out the type of beer that's right
upload so title reference genome refers
to the reference to you are going to you
- the engine are modeled genome GT depth
means that the genome and the GPX file
annotations are already represented
usually we will be using today for using
only this option and here are the
organism for this genome and this is of
course needed only for uploading the
story so these are all the organisms
another option might be our genome and
that means that you are uploading your
own customized genome you can also be
uploading those that you know
engineer firm customized genome and
together for these two options the
organism will not present today we will
only be using the our model gene IDs we
will be using the human human genome the
newest human genome is one for the PDX
Dennis said we will be using the
continuity human and
the data format we will be working with
today is fast cue other formats are also
possible the most popular formats of NGS
data are fast queue and fast a for
months you can be also working with
alignment data already aligned data with
some of us and we can be using of course
simulations for which he don't mean data
previously Clara the NGS data comes in
two formats single and and parent and
this should also be identified here in
this before you actually approach early
so we will be using prepare and a or
today after you have chosen what is
needed here you multiply we will be
using today as buildings but look of
many funds and maybe as buildings
together today but of course you can
upload data from personal computer or
HTTP I could upload your dinner you are
asking to find the groups doctor they
let it go will go into how to choose how
many foods you eat so I will not go into
this now so I will do cancel no routes
and then I am ready to actually prepare
my I'd like
so when you are ready to prepare the
pipeline you will notice some bones
appear in a bright black but up sanction
and others are great only the black ones
are you are able to and impress at each
time this was many for your engines
because we think that choosing sometimes
choosing balance is not so simple so we
wanted to help the user move along and
to creating this paper also each time
you press the button you will see where
the no explained and sometimes it will
also have to choose parameters so let's
begin with the start so I press Start
the pop-up window comes up with
explanation of the algorithm in my case
just what is a sequencing and okay
sometimes this site was crackers but
that out now when I chose start I have
few options as you can see and have some
of them up here in bright colors which
is that I can actually choose them and
some heart rate which I cannot respond
let me try talk and again explanation no
parameters
okay when I am done I simply press end
and save my pipeline I can choose a name
of the pipeline that say test this is
just for you and you can run real
pipeline
when the pipeline is finished there are
two options you can always go to my high
plans and check and the stages of the
pipeline you can also receive an email
you also receive an email with
notification of problems of the pipeline
or alleged violent husband have finished
we will start with an overview of
transcriptome data and initial analysis
we will then proceed to unsupervised
analysis tools for analyzing expression
table including animation and pathway
analysis then we will have a section
unsupervised tools and we hope to finish
with the time for practical independent
analysis of Eden when the team will be
there to help with this equation a
reminder about the workshop we will have
suite with race when you can ask dr.
collect questions or ask for assistance
of our team let us know is meet such
assistance right now not to chat or if
you're an audience he's asks you and let
us take no one would be great to make
sure that everyone has I was brilliant
for only and we will love that wonderful
thank you
to our online participants is everything
going ruined if there are some issues
you can probably Bengals on the chat box
or you can drop us an email now
proceeding to the next one now it's -
dr. Kevin Campbell to start up with new
things
you
on the together who can you please
unmute yourself yeah okay okay okay so
before we start please let us make sure
that we all have an access to the tab or
bar in the platform and we all have the
set of file of files we'll need so we're
all have an access primarily to the
screen with sections we'll be working
with and we're all have the set of files
out of which our main sound subfolder
will be main files the additional thing
we'll need is any program for table
procession for example conventional
Microsoft Excel OpenOffice or something
like that
so if it is okay with these points let
us start with working with RNA
sequencing data sets just from the
beginning so in order to understand what
is the processing of RNA sequencing data
we first need to understand the scheme
that is used in at a wet lab level to
process all this data to prepare rescue
files so initially we start with a
genome and as you know perfectly well
certain sections of genome code for
proteins so these sections are called
genes protein are not produced directly
from genes while there is an
intermediate step the production of
messenger RNA
ranae's and all the cells in an organism
have the same genes but these genes have
different expression levels in different
tissues in different organs in different
cells and so the expression level
so ideally we want to measure the rate
of production of proteins but
technically it's more an travail and
it's more expensive to look at proteins
however it also can be done for example
them mass spec experiments yet looking
at all the transcripts at the our
messenger RNA level is relatively
straightforward and relatively cheap and
from the high from the little detailed
viewport but the situation here is the
following the situation here is the
following
all messenger rna's are simply cut
randomly into short pieces initially we
do not know the origin for each piece
but it in any way more transcripts
corresponding to a gene we have in a
sample more short segments really
originated from these transcripts are
observed in the health stack of these
short sequences shot but these shut
sequences are sometimes called
reads so in order to analyze the
expression levels in order to analyze
the activity of various genes all we
need to do is to map these reads back to
transcripts and this task is feasible as
for model organisms and in particular
for humans we know the nucleotide
sequences for all the genomes so we
simply map the reads read by a sequence
machine bed transcripts and if there are
many reads mapped on a gene or metal
yeah let it be methanol gene then the
expression level of this gene is high if
there are only few reads maternal gene
the expressed level is low and for many
genes there are no reads mapped on the
gene it means that the expression
of this gene is zero or little however
if we look deeper into the details the
process is just the following it indeed
begins with shattering our transcripts
all messenger RNA is a sample for
example the ultrasound oh there are
various other technologies but then
there is an intermediate step required
for sequence a machine to be able to
capture these short segments these reads
so adapters allocated generally from
both sides of the reads this such as the
same sequences that are negated well
roughly speaking to the beginning and to
the end of all the reads then so-called
PCR amplification step is performed when
for each segment with adapters negated
multiple copies are produced at each
iteration of this PCR amplification the
number of copies is doubled so for
example if we have six rounds of PCR
amplification the number of copies will
be 2 power 6 that is 64 if we have for
example only 2 rounds of PCR
amplification we get only 4 copies for
each segment and so after this step
there are multiple copies for each
initial shot sequence for PCR
amplification there is no guarantee that
the efficiency of this stage will be
equivalent for all short reads so for
some short reads
there will be more copies for some short
reads there will be less copies in
comparison with the number of we expect
finally at the stage of reading all
these short sequences all these reads by
a sequencing machine not all
segments are taken but only a subset is
in fact randomly selected from the hill
totality of what we have in a sample and
if we perform multiple steps of PCR
amplification then the probability of
getting several of reading several
copies of the same initial segment
becomes rather high however if the
initial amount of RNA material is
sufficient if the initial is number of
steps in PCR amplification is relatively
small work for example six seven five
there the number of these artificial
which are duplicates so the copies read
originated from the same short segment
is relatively low so these short
segments are read by the by sequencing
machine and then the process is
performed as we initially discussed all
these reads are mapped on gene
sequencing and gene sequences and
expression levels are estimated so this
technical pipeline provides us and gives
us an insight into how we should
organize a pipeline for analyzing the
results of sequencing how we should what
models should we use when we have test
few of Esther files originated from a
sequencing machine so at a hardware
level or better to say at a wet lab
level the first step was the allegation
of adapters so a standard pipeline for
the analysis for the estimation of
expression levels starts with removing
these adapters additionally sometimes it
is a good idea to trim ends of reads as
this ends generally have lower quality
then as we might have these are
duplicates so multiple copies of the
same initial
segment red we can remove this piece our
duplicates simply by removing reeds that
are identical then we can perform
mapping but there are multiple options
for mapping it can be performed either
on transcriptome so unknown transcripts
in this case will quantify only
expression levels of known genes another
option is to perform mapping on a genome
and to at least try to identify novel
transcripts that is new isoforms for
already known genes or even completely
new genes definitely high throughput
high throughput methods including RNA
sequencing give us an ability to do to
do it but an independent validation will
be required to be sure like identify
transcripts really exist so it's not
just a consequence of an analyzing to
large amount of data so combined
strategies are also possible a slight
problem with this analysis is that it's
really time consuming the initial size
of files is several gigabytes up to
thousands of gigabytes so even uploading
these files takes time
processing also takes time
however creation of this pipeline is
fast and there's generally no problem
with time taken for processing for
quantification of expression level as
what lab stage takes even much longer
and sample preparation is also a
relatively long task so in order to have
a training of creation a pipeline aimed
at analyzing expression levels for
example of known genes let us try to log
into the platform
and see how it can be done we won't
start this pipeline as it takes time too
much time to be finished in the frames
of our workshop but still we'll create
it so as you saw in the introduction we
can select the section rnaseq or chip
sack data so the top left section and
start with with setting main options the
main options for the model organism
include the organism itself for example
for Homo sapiens we select homo sapiens
one of the genome assemblies the format
of input files generally if we start
with raw data it's fescue and the type
of reads single and or parent reads then
we proceed to uploading files as we
initially discussed normal size of test
cube files of Vesta files is really
large but some files are already
uploaded to the platform and in this
case to avoid multiple uploading of the
same files we can use bulk upload for
just uploading a file via link to its
location in a server so we can select an
option bulk upload and from the file
list we have specifically from the
folder main files specifically from the
folder main files we can select a link
to files that are already present for
example links to samples will give us a
link to two samples we have so we open
these files and continue we open these
files and go on
so going on is just pressing defined
groups in this first analysis and this
first analysis we won't perform any
deeper analysis differential expression
analysis for example we'll just quantify
the expression level of genes that is
why we simply skip all additional steps
and start creating the pipeline so again
this pipeline just follows this pipeline
just follows the logic of the wet lab
preparation of the sequencing data so
after selecting start and conformant by
pressing ok we select a module that
performs adapt removal and potential
additional trimming of flow quality and
of reads then we select a model for PCR
duplicates cleaning then we select a
model for mapping on transcriptome if we
want to have simply expression levels of
known genes or isoforms there are at
least two options the standard bowtie -
and also standard mapper PWA so we can
select any but after mapping we
additionally needs to go from read
counts to expression level
quantification so we'll need to discuss
what are the standard units for the
quantification of expression levels in
any way this job can be performed by the
our same module this job can be formed
by the RSM model this here called our
same express - table and the desired
expression units fragments per kilobytes
per million expected counts on
transcripts per million can't be
selected as a job option so
that is all all we need to do next is to
finish our pipeline give it a name for
example expression level quantification
but you can give any name you like and
if we wanted to start this pipeline we
could simply press run pipeline but as I
said there's no reason doing it's now or
ever later
definitely you can check the result
[Music]
so let us check let us check whether
there are any problem at this stage or
everything is fine so if everything is
fine we go further and discuss our
options at creating these pipelines
available literature shows that trimming
low-quality ends and even trimming
adapters really improves the quality of
expression level quantification but this
improvement is moderate
moreover removing of Bashar duplicates
is sometimes not desirable as in many
cases these PCR duplicates are not
artificial but there there are natural
identical reefs for example in case of
analyzing short sequencing micro rna's
as an example identical breeds emerge
from biological origin of the analysis
so in some cases these are duplicates
removal can even introduce bias to the
result in case if want to at least Luke
try to look at null transcripts we
simply add several modules to our
pipelines this modules
additionally before mapping on genome
gather exams into potentially new
isoforms or even potential new genes and
then combine in the set of initial
analogies with the set of genes that are
identified by the pipeline so
technically and algorithmically it's not
a simple task
but from the point of view of the user
the difference between these pipelines
is just an addition of several modules
independently of selecting or not
selecting some pre-processing steps we
need to discuss what are the standard
units for the quantification of jeans or
isoforms expression levels so initially
we started with an idea that Maureen's
we have met on a gene the higher the
expression level of this gene is but let
us consider the following two facts
first imagine we have two messenger
rna's the first corresponds to gene a
and the second corresponds to gene B and
imagine that gene a is much longer than
GMP so after shattering into small
segments this one my messenger RNA will
give essentially more reads essentially
more segments in comparison with
messenger RNA in comparison with
transcript that corresponds to gene B so
initially we have one messenger RNA for
both genes but after shattering we have
essentially different number of reads
addition essentially different number of
short segments associated with these
genes so if we want to perform scaling
that takes this fact into consideration
we should use not just the number of
reads mapped on gene but number of genes
scaled by the gene length so tenant Lee
here gene length is measured in
kilobases another fact is the following
imagine that we have one sample that is
sequence twice and in one case the
number of reads sequence
is for example two times higher than in
the other keys so in other words one
sequencing is twice deeper in comparison
with the other one again we deal with
the same expressions of the same genes
we simply change experimental conditions
and get approximately two full
difference in the number of genes mapped
on a gene just because in one of the
experiments the total number of genes
was two times higher so in order to
perform scaling that takes this fact in
taken into consideration the previous
expression is additional divided into
the total number of mapped reads so
these two scaling is scaling by a gene
length and a scaling by total number of
med reads
is an attempt to reduce the dependence
of the expression level we finally have
on experimental conditions and on gene
length to have something uniform with
respect to genes and experiments so this
is one of the very popular measures for
measuring expression levels fragments
per kilobase per million map reads
another unit for expression level
communication is very similar and for
each sample for example this second
measure is simply proportional to the
first one the number the complete number
of transcript of fragments per million
for each sample is just skilled in such
a way that the sound will be 1 million
so the new unit we have is called
transcription per million what is the
logic behind these new unit
we can define it in slightly in a
slightly different way new units can be
defined as follows
let us consider an expression that is
equal to the number of reads mapped on a
gene multiple byte mean length of reads
and / gene length so what is the meaning
what is the meaning of this expression
so having a product of number of reads
mapped on a gene and read main length we
have the number of nucleotides in fact
total number of nucleotides originated
read sequenced from a gene after
division by a gene length we have an
approximation of the number of
transcripts sequenced associated with
these genes soon number of reads mapped
on a gene multiple by read mean length
and divided by jing-mei is simply an
approximation of the total number of
transcripts sequenced for this gene if
we divide this expression by the total
number by the sum of all these
expressions over all genes and multiple
for example by 1 million will have the
approximate number of transcripts
associated with this gene in every
million transcripts we have in our
sample so that is why transcript per
million is a unit that has a natural
interpretation for example unlike
friends / kilobase per million map reads
unit another fact we should take into
consideration when working with
sequencing data is that in case of any
standard unit counts f PK m tpem in many
cases it's a good idea to do from
initial linear scale to logarithmic
scale to log scale for example by
calculating
a logarithm steadily this logarithm has
these two and one of the reasons for
doing salute is just a statistical one
through many genes expression of these
genes expression levels of these genes
have log normal distribution so after
taking logarithm we obtain normal
distribution that is very good from the
point of view of statistical analysis so
parametric testing is applicable for
this case another reason is that
relative difference is more meaningful
in the biological case than the absolute
difference for example if we say that
the difference in expression levels is
100 F becames
or tpms the information contained in
this sentence is relatively low if we
say that the difference is twofold
threefold
for folks we give more information to
reader about an expression change of
this gene and these relative changes are
quantified very naturally in the
logarithmic scale so two fold change is
simply a difference in one unit in the
logarithmic scale in case if the base is
2 4 fold difference equals to equals
difference equal to 2 in the logarithmic
scale and so on the problem here is that
the logarithm of zero is undefined and
for many genes their expression level
quantification is simply zero so who
can't be formed log scale indirectly to
avoid this problem a small shift is
added in many cases the shifts simply
equals 1
it does not affect quantification of
expression levels of genes with
relatively high expression or even
moderate expressed genes but it saves us
in case of genes having very low
expression or zero level expression
please keep in mind that genes with low
level expression or a hard form the
analysis if their expression level is
measured on precisely by almost any type
of the analysis including RNA sequencing
so if the expression level of the gene
is really low for example zero we should
take we should keep in mind that it's
just an approximation of an expression
level with potentially high error
I just technical error so what we have
after the pipeline that provides us
expression levels of all known genes let
us just take a look and compare the
effect of various pre-processing steps
we'll do it briefly and then go on with
more hands-on experience so in the files
you have there is also a folder with
some output files so the subfolder read
output files and there there's a
subfolder
in a sec comparison in the sub folder
you can find a file you can find the
file with results of pipeline we
initially prepared together standard
processing which includes both adaptive
streaming and bizarre duplicates removal
short pre-processing no Bussard
applicants removal
and just no prep recessing everything
starts with mapping unknown transcripts
and here units are love to he is are
just yeah look fpkm
with base equal to two and shift one so
what do we have here what do we have
after this comparison is the fact rest
generally indeed processing scheme has
very minor effect on the results however
if we completely avoid pre-processing
this effect is higher than in case if we
avoid just one step of pre-processing
but if we look at certain individual
transcripts the dense emerged from
different schemes of pre-processing is
really high so please again take in keep
in mind that it is a logarithmic scale
so for example the difference for a
transcript for dot I point at is more
than two fold so if we change our prep
recession scheme we get very different
result
that is why for the majority of high
throughput methods including Peron a
sequencing additional what lab
validation is highly desirable if our
analysis is aimed at the identification
of a small number of individual
transcripts so in any case this pipeline
that is technically very simple just
provides us with a huge number of dip of
various expression levels in case if we
also try to identify novel transcripts
the length of the set of expression
levels is even more high as we get
expression levels for potential new
isoforms of potential and new genes it
additionally the express levels for
initially known isoforms and genes so
the main question is what to do next
with all these files how this what
information can be obtained further from
all these expression levels which are
infeasible for the analysis with just
eyes which are infeasible for manual
analysis
so let us currently have a short break
discuss the questions and then go on
with the analysis of what can be done
with all this data how this data can be
analyzed so currently if this break
please feel free to ask questions thank
you and all the online users if there's
any question any doubts please feel free
to tag us chat with us on the chat box
we are probably having a break for like
two minutes just to make sure that
everyone is on the same page
audience do we have any questions
okay so probably let us try to go for an
hour to have a bit longer next break so
while we still have our attention let us
briefly discuss standard ways for
differential expression analysis and
starch pathway and gene set enrichment
analysis so in many cases samples can be
initially divided into several groups in
the simplest case just in two groups and
the idea that lies behind the analysis
is to identify genes that have
initiative essentially different
expression levels between these two
groups for example genes with high
expression level in one group and low
expression level in another group what
are the main characteristics of this
differential expression what are the
main characteristics that should be kept
in mind when thinking about the
differential expression analysis
naturally the first characteristic is
full change so the difference between
mean expression levels in the first
group and in the second group so it is
very natural to say that the expression
is sufficiently different if for example
the difference between means is at least
two fold forever please consider for
example we have in this slide in the
right intuitively we understand that
there is no differential expression if
blue dots visualize samples from the
first group and red dots visualize
samples from the other group if the
little figure at the lower plot we see
Clee differential expression we see that
the expression level of a gene is higher
in blue
group in comparison with the red group
the interesting thing here is that the
difference between mean expression
levels for the top figure and for the
bottom figure are identical so in both
figures blue group has mean expression
level two fold higher in comparison with
the red group here I pay our attention
to the fact that we when we speak about
mean expression level steadily we speak
about standard conventional breath
metric mean in logarithmic scale and it
corresponds to geometric mean in initial
linear scale but here the numbers are
associated with the logarithmic scale so
that is why to these pictures show that
evidently we can't look only at the
difference between means only at the
difference between mean expression
levels to estimate the differential
expression rate for a gene we
additionally should add some statistical
significance that as an example we'll
compare the difference between means
with variation of expression levels
inside these groups the statistics that
lies just behind a conventional students
t-test so log full change is always
supplied by statistical significance
level probability value or p-value what
is what's the meaning of a p-value
p-value is simply a probability of
observing the difference we have or even
higher difference in case when in
reality there is no difference in
expression of these genes in two groups
so for example if p-value equals 0.01
that
is 1% it means that the probability that
were mistaken telling that this gene is
differentially expressed is simply 1
percent one out of hundreds but here
which simultaneously tests multiple
hypotheses will simultaneously consider
multiple genes so imagine the following
situation we have one coin with drop
this coin 10 times and this coin falls
the same side up for all 10 and times it
doesn't look suspicious probably it does
as the probability of having the same
site for a coin up in ten throws is
really low but if we ask asks several
thousand dollars a million of people do
this experiment take a coin threw it for
ten times and observe the result
definitely will have many people with
coin with a coin that fell all ten times
up the same site it does not mean that
all these people have while non-standard
coins it simply means that the number of
people number of tested hypotheses is so
large that even events with low
probability are observed soon we need to
correct this standard p-value - and a
correction should be aimed at
considering this fact of simultaneous
testing of multiple hypotheses that is
why standardly this argue is supported
by stoop old adjusted p-value that has
different names slightly different
statistical minions and sometimes it is
called adjusted pvalue sometimes it is
called Q value sometimes it is called
for example false discovery rate so
false discovery rate means for example
false discovery rate of 5%
0.05 means that if we take all the genes
if we take all the hypotheses with after
our lower than 0.05 then only about 5%
of genes in this list would be false
discoveries so there would be some false
discoveries here but the majority
discoveries will be correct
additionally standardly people also look
at mean expression level of gene we're
working ease and occasion is required
for low expressed genes as we initially
discussed that generally the precision
of estimation of expression level is
much lower for low express genes in
comparison with high it with jeans with
high expression to let us try to see how
differential expression analysis at
least at the level of unadjusted p-value
of standard T value can be performed
manually as it is really simple
so imagine we have an output of a
pipeline that simply measured expression
levels of genes soon let us take the
file from the folder main files for
differential expression fpkm
well and try to open it in an excel or a
similar to just to have a normal
visualization so what do we have here
this is an example we
two groups associated with breast cancer
cell lines the first six samples as you
see from the titles are associated with
one subtype of breast cancer and the
second pack of samples five samples is
associated with so-called normal like
subtype and here we have about sixty
thousand genes the majority of these
genes simply have zero expression but
the question is how to identify
differentially expressed genes quickly
if units that are used here for the
Analia for the quantification of
expression levels are fragments per
kilobase per million so it became so
what is the natural the standard
pipeline the standard set of steps for
differential expression analysis if we
limit ourselves with very simple
statistics again first standard Clee we
go from linear scale to logarithmic
scale to be able to apply various
Prometric statistical models for example
t-test so let's try to do it together
just to see that the task is really
simple so first let us just for transfer
all this data to logarithmic scale it
can be easily done in multiple tools in
our for example if you like coding but
even table processing to such an excel
give us everything we need
i just copy title to see number of
columns in a more simple way but the
first thing i do is i'm take and go into
logarithmic scale i say that here i need
to compute logarithm
with bass with these two in certain
cases semicolon is used to separate the
first argument and a base in Excel in
certain systems it is calmer so
definitely you know what's the correct
way for giving formulas in your system
again sometimes it's a semicolon put
here
sometimes it's comma then we simply
transfer this formula to all our other
cells in order to do it for example in
the standard Excel I can press on a
bottom right corner and move the Mars to
the right and then by again double
clicking the corner by double clicking
this corner I trust put this formula to
all the cells in our file but in many
cases we see an undefined value here the
reason is that as we discussed initially
the logarithm of zero is undefined and
standardly when we go to the logarithmic
scale we add a small shift the argument
the expression level measured in FP
Keynes for example for example less
shift equal well classical value 1 and
just transfer this formula to all the
cells so I'll add colors to see
difference with to see groups more
visible and then Oh what are the mean
characteristics we'll use as we
discussed it might be interesting to
look at mean expression levels to be
cautious with jeans with low expression
level so let us just add mean expression
level for the group one for clothing low
and mean for two so it's gonna be done
with a function average classical system
here I've got just recall it
localization so the standard formula is
just average and you show which sales
should be considered here so here's the
formula I needs here to change the
function just as currently I have
computer with relatively strange
localization and next I add a similar at
a similar mean logarithmic mean
expression level so average the second
group again in my case I simply have to
replace average with that same command
in my current localization so here we
see just mean values heavenly various we
can compute log for change immediately
log full change
blog for change is a simple difference
between me levels in logarithmic scale
so what's the meaning of this
logarithmic fault change in a standard
scale for example log for change equal
to minus 1 means that the expression
reduced to fold mark for change equal to
2 simply to 2 means that the growth of
expression level was 4
if an expression if block for change is
2 point 3 it means that the growth in
the initial linear scale is 2 power 2
point 3 so here we got our four changes
in logarithmic scale and in order to get
p-value in a standard T test case we can
use again a standard Excel function as p
values are provided by standard T test
function again in my localization I have
the same function with slightly
different name with a bad C and here we
need to specify the first group of
samples the second group of samples the
second group of samples if a as you type
one-tailed or two-tailed standardly it
is two-tailed and fine
finally some statistical parameter
related to our assumption about
variation of two samples so here we have
at least two
clickable options that arguments two and
three so first I'll select two and then
I'll show you I'll select three so here
we have our P values we have our P
values please pay your attention to the
fact that if we use a slightly different
statistical model we'll have sometimes
similar but really different
let values P values here for example in
one statistical model we have p value
for the third line equal to zero points
to zero in the case of another
statistics just a moment it became 0.19
and so on this really is our really
similar this difference is insignificant
in this case but we just see that
application of different statistical
methods gives us different T values and
that is why it's really important to
specify the type of the differential
expression analysis that is used as
really different approaches can provide
us different results with slightly
different sets of differentially
expressed genes so what we have here is
logarithmic fold change and p value for
each gene and in order for example to
get genes with it that are
conventionally codes up regulated so
differentially expressed genes that are
upregulated we need to set thresholds
for example greater greater for
logarithmic fold change so we select
only genes
which logarithmic fault change is at
least 1 and a conventional threshold for
p-value is 0.05 but again I pay you
attention to the fact that standardly
adjusted p-values are used not initial
p-values
he will just avoided a step of
computation of adjusted to Vegas so the
thresholds 0.05 for p-value or better
much better adjusted to value for
example if they are and at least two
fold change that is equivalent to 1 in
logarithmic scale are in fact softest
thresholds that are generally used in
some types of the analysis for example
if we analyze micro knees even softer
thresholds are applied sometimes for
example so the threshold on full change
but these cases are rare and so doing so
we have a list of genes that are
upregulated it means that for the second
condition they have statistically
significant significantly higher
expression level in comparison with the
first condition if we want to have
downregulated genes we simply select
genes with sufficiently negative with
sufficiently negative logarithmic
threshold for example log for change
lower than minus 1 so if there are too
many genes in this list then we can
apply other thresholds the reason for
having such a great number of genes here
the primary reason is that here we
simply dealt with unadjusted p-values
that really increased the number of
genes forever
these statistics we used here is not
well the most powerful one in a way
statistical models based on negative
binomial distributions are used much in
many cases and provides in many cases
better results in comparison with these
t-test we used and in order to get
differentially expressed genes
originated from more complicated
statistical analysis it is much more
simple to avoid performing all the steps
just by hands we can prepare a pipeline
that does all the job we can prepare
pipelines and does all the jobs and let
us see how it can be done let us again
go to the platform it will be one of our
probably last pipeline that won't be run
today the rest of the pipeline's will be
launched and we'll see their results so
let us create a pipeline for the
differential expression analysis that
uses much more complicated statistics in
comparison with the students t-test so
again we gave you today RNA sequencing
section again we set type of reads to
the parent and select comma sapiens and
as an organism and in this case again to
avoid uploading huge files we use bulk
uploading but currently select links to
11 samples you saw in the previous excel
file so the file links silhou versus and
like and go on the lower five samples
here are associated with the second
group normal like other
first six samples are associated with
the first group so in order to perform
differential expression analysis we need
to specify which samples are associated
with each condition so we simply drag
and drop drop samples I said that the
lower five are associated with the
second condition with drag and drop
samples to the boxes associated with our
groups
we start the group so here we can next
press Continue in this simple analysis
we don't need a trivial contour so we
simply submit it and as we again start
with raw files initially we can perform
the same quantification of we can
perform the same quantification of
expression levels I just recreate the
pipeline we initially created but at the
last step we add a model for
differential expression analysis for
example H R or D SEC 2 both of these
models are based on negative binomial
distribution models but details are
different so we can add any of these to
two models so here is the pipeline that
after pressing end would be ready for
launching in reality these more
complicated models for the analysis of
differential expression do you not with
non-trivial units of expression levels
in reality they all take simple counts
from our SEM and perform post-processing
perform quantification in their internal
units inside these jobs inside these
models so again as this pipeline starts
with initial raw fescue data
it's rather slow but let us look at the
output of this pipeline in order to do
it again we might go to the subfolder
res output files here sup for the
differential expression and we have
outputs for both
it's our analysis type and the sec - and
then it's this type it's simpler to open
these files again in table processing
environment for example Excel and to see
just the type of the output we have here
for both cases that main columns are
full change of lock full change which
tells us the difference between mean
levels statistical significance here
adjusted p-value and the basic well the
basem expression level it is a mean
expression level in the first group or a
mean expression level in all the
compared samples in the pass of the tube
so in any case we have three we have
three main three main columns so here
they are four basic two outputs just a
similar thing is for HR output so
logarithmic for change statistical
significance and in a way mean
expression levels of base level that can
be used to carefully examine genes with
lower expression so ahead of the
complete table we can simply look only
at genes with the highest level of
difference expression with the height
absolute values of for changes and with
lowest with values of adjusted to varies
for example values of as they are as
close to zero as possible but what we
can do hand these lists so let us for
for example consider an example that we
identified certain genes of interest we
want to look at further so just a simple
to take it as a simple example in the
folder with the main files we have for
example file cell lines 15 genes which
contains kind of information currently
it's even not important what this
information is for 15 genes another
option is we could simply set thresholds
and get genes with the highest level of
differential expression in the case of
toggle binds a platform and in the case
of many other platforms the primary type
of the identifier used is an sample ID
so it's relatively hard to understand
the function of a gene to understand
what's going on with a gene using just
an assemble ID so there are only few
people who remember in sample IDs for
many genes gene symbols or gene ontology
terms are much more informative but in
many tables we do not have this
information but at an information about
gene names gene ontology terms is really
simple and it can be performed not
simply by hands but again using the
platform so let us just create a
pipeline and run it to see how simple it
is so let us go to the areas of the
analysis areas of the analysis then go
to the utilities section then go to the
utilities section
upload a file we want to work with in
this case we perform normal uploading of
the file so it's a standard case from
the subfolder main files for example let
us upload this file cell lines 15 genes
and simply continue so if we want to
simply annotate genes by adding their
gene ontology terms gene symbols and
stuff like that we create a pipeline
with just one mounted annotation
annotation so in our case the default
options will do the main options here
are whether to output gene ontology cut
categories or not whether the table you
use as an input has a header and the
number of column in which in-sample ids
are allocated other options are
commented so comments simple pop-up
helps can be viewed after pointing into
the items near each parameter so we
confirm using default parameters give a
name to this pipeline for example
suitable annotation and run this
pipeline so it may take up to several
seconds or even the half minute to start
to
generally it's a simple desk well in any
case it can be the speed he can be
increased so if the platform does not
start the pipeline for example we can
simply reload a page go to my pipeline
section which includes all the
information about pipelines select our
pipeline and then press run pipeline
again so after the pipeline is started
we can simply monitor the progress
either in the my pipeline section or
just looking at one pipeline that we
have created but if there are if the
number of genes of interest for example
number of genes identified as the french
the express genes number of genes with
good adjusted p-value and good full
change is relatively large it's very
hard to make certain conclusions just
looking at annotations of individual
genes so what are the standard steps of
further analysis of lists of
differentially expressed genes there are
at least two options the first option is
pathway or gene enrichment analysis
based simply on the list of gene names
this very simple analysis can be
performed online for example using a
standard tool the reads for enrichment
analysis simple but widely used gold
buried it's not the unique tool but it's
one of the most popular tools for this
type
the job so if we have certain
differentially expressed genes for
example let me take HR output as an
example and let me again take genes with
relatively small pause discovery rate
relatively small adjusted prevail use to
have they are lower than for example
0.05 and block full change for example
higher than one so I have here more than
700 genes that it's really infeasible to
look through all these genes manually
but we can copy all these genes we can
simply copy all these genes and try to
see whether many of these genes belongs
to the same pathway or belong belong to
the same set of genes with the same
function so for example we can do
directly to require Seidel if we don't
remember its name just find it fear
words david enrichment as the usage here
is really simple we paste our list we
paste our list let me just show it a bit
slower we start our analysis to press
start we paste our list to the box we'll
try to paste a list we select the type
of our identifiers in our case it's an
sample identifiers and sample gene IDs
we set an option that is a gene list of
interest and simply
this list so it's simpler to do it in
the previous version of David however
not the new version also works good but
through this version that 6.7 is
sometimes more stable so you can use any
of options so in case of the previous
version will get slightly different
enriched categories so again we set
identifier type to example GID would
tell that it's a gene list we submit
this gene list well it says that many
identifiers are unknown to the system
and will have will currently see what's
the reason what is the reason here
so in our case but it says that it
cannot process all our identifiers just
a moment so what let me open it
what's the reason the reason is in our
case in structure of names and sample
identifiers has have version at the end
so the simple attempt at least to create
the situation that is really frequent is
to try to cut this version so the number
that follows dot for example we can say
replace and replace all the text that
gives after dot including dot with an
empty set so here I did it and we can
try to supply this shortened list of
example identifiers to drive it again so
start analysis to probably it's the only
problem with identifiers we'll have
today we said identifiers ID to an
sample sorry and sample gene ID we said
the type of the gene list to the main
one we submit this list and here after
removing version we see that there is no
problem with conversion and we can
select organism in our case Homo sapiens
so it's a standard problem with various
gene identifiers we have in
bioinformatics and some systems have
automatic conversion tools some work
only with ensamble IDs some work with
only interest at this some work only
with gene symbols so there's a certain
mass with these identifiers but
unfortunately it's standard for work
with different types of gene identifiers
here and what David does is finding
enriched categories we can look at these
categories as just pressing it for
example functional annotation charts we
see the name of categories and the main
parameter here is adjusted by value here
we see so-called Benjamin a horbet of
Benjamin accredited p-values so the last
column contains adjusted p-values which
tell us in which functional categories
in which pathways well there's a
statistical enrichment with the genes
from our list so this type of pathway
analysis is really frequent but it is
too simple for many cases as this type
of analysis ignores the majority of
information we have after gene after
differential expression analysis here we
simply ignored full changes here we
simply ignored p-values we ignored even
the directions of changes of genes we
set hard thresholds so if gene satisfy
these thresholds we included it into the
list if gene was very close but was not
inside the zone it was completely
excluded from the list that is why
setting slightly different thresholds
can give us slightly different gene
lists and different results of gene
Richmond analysis the second type of the
analysis works not only with gene names
or gene titles gene identifiers but it
takes additional information we have
after differential expression analysis
I mean information related to for
example full change or other
characteristics that represent the rate
of differential expression so in order
to test these type of the differential
expression analysis let us create and
run one more pipeline and then discuss
what's going on there so would be form
differential expression analysis well at
least we discussed a pipeline that can
simply die do this job and after this
pipeline we had logarithmic fall changes
for each gene this logarithmic fall
changes along with all other information
are stored for example for this excel
file in main file stock folder the file
called the SEC - full out and not dot
txt so what information is contained
here it's a simple output of the SEC
tool additionally annotated with gene
symbols gene symbols could be added via
annotation simple annotation - we just
discussed so let's go back to one with
one step and look at the progress of our
pipeline we started so I simply reload
the page to see the current state and I
see that my pipeline the previous
pipeline I started is done the main
output for this pipeline are stored in
download pipeline output files section
and if we uploaded a file related
associated with 15 genes our main output
we'll be the file with the same name but
with the suffix out so what's there in
this file again I open it in Excel to
have clear visualization the first
columns are the columns we had in the
initial file but then for each line the
model adds gene symbol gene description
available gene ontology categories and
all this supporting information so
there's absolutely no need in manual
addition of gene symbols when we need
them
annotation model simply does this job
and so this annotation model was applied
to her output of differential expression
analysis and gene names were added
simply because certain gene set
enrichment analysis tools work perfectly
well with gene symbols but not with an
sampled gene identifiers so in our case
we have a complete table that
particularly has a rate of differential
expression measured by law to full
change for each gene symbol and we can
perform the identification of pathways
or gene sets enriched by differentially
expressed genes without setting any
thresholds and including all the genes
into the input data as module itself
loops at the value of differential
expression characteristic for example of
two full change and makes a decision
whether the differential expression is
high allow simply in comparison with
other values we have in order to create
a pipeline which performs these analysis
were also need to go to the utility
section
and upload an input file in our case for
example if we're dealing with D SEC to
differential expression analysis there
is a two full-out annotation file so it
may take some time for the uploading we
go on we start our pipeline we select in
this case the human gauge model which is
a simple application of gauge enrichment
analysis to humans and let us look at
parameters we have two we have here so
and simultaneously look at the input
file our input table has headers for
columns that is why we said column had a
present - yes this model deals with two
types of gene IDs gene symbols and
address gene identifiers gene symbols
are specified in the second column and
that is why we set the column with gene
IDs - - as ensembl IDs are unacceptable
logarithmic for changes our
characteristic of differential
expression are stalled are stored in the
fourth column that is why we said : with
gene differential expression measured to
four then we selects the statistical
model for the analysis for logarithmic
full change as a characteristic of
differential expression level we
generally select parametric model for
example if the arrow that is suggested
p-value as a characteristic with general
select non parametric model then we
select a set of pathways or gene sets
analyzed in this analysis for example
CAG
Nancy is a set of CAC metastatic and
signaling pathways we select genes will
consider only up regulated only down
regulated upregulated and downregulated
considered booth but separately or
considered in combination and who
additional threshold for visualization
so from pathways that will be enriched
with statistical significance with F of
they're lower than zero in our case 0.1
additional plus will be drawn in case of
using KEGG pathways so we set these
options we complete creation of our
pipeline for example human age test and
run it
so our pipeline is started and similarly
to the david case we'll have here in
rich pathways we'll see it in a while
but here we do not need to set any
specific thresholds thresholds here we
use in fact complete information that we
have
after the differential expression
analysis and so the result are believed
to be more biologically relevant so soon
we'll see the output of this pipeline it
takes some time as the input includes as
we saw data for thousands and tens of
thousands of genes and after half of the
result for this pipeline in fact we'll
complete the discussion related to
standard differential expression
analysis of RNA sequencing data so the
analysis standard for many experimental
setups just to summarize it standardly
we simply create a pipeline which in
this platform includes prayer processing
of sequencing data mapping
quantification of expression level of
genes and identification of
differentially expressed genes by
computing all changes and which is much
harder statistical significance of the
difference for each gene if we deal with
essential number of differentially
expressed genes then we might want to
have a deeper insight
into the biology of the whole set of
different Express genes and it can be
done by gene set or pathway enrichment
analysis which identifies the function
the pathway group of known group of
genes enriched by genes identified as
differentially expressed in our
experiment
so we'll see what processes are
different for our compare group of
samples for this type of the analysis we
initially needs to know the groups so if
we have several groups in the simplest
case two groups we can do all the steps
we can identify differentially expressed
genes we can perform gene enrichment
analysis and to have its result so
generally it takes several minutes at
these points let us have a short break
and discuss questions if required and
after this break we'll look at the
output and the next sections of our
today workshop hopefully will be more
dynamical will run more pipelines will
discuss more things in the next section
associated with the unsupervised
analysis type where we do not know
initially what are the subgroups and
when we even do not know where these
subgroups exist or not so please feel
free to ask questions
of ends thank you dr. dubenko I hope the
workshop is going good and repeating in
my sentence again if anyone has any
question leaves me free to reach out to
us through a chat box that we have on
our sometime for this question in any
case for example have 5 minutes or 10
minutes break if you wish then discuss
these questions if there will be any
hopefully they will onto our machine ok
so sorry it's work it's not perfectly
well to you as you adjust closer to the
microphone could you please repeat the
question yeah sure okay sorry yeah this
technical problem now
sounds filed so this is the question
professor tout that I got from our
pipeline after performing de-sect to
analysis for irritation of the genes
that were
to be differentially expressed it should
it be done through David out of a
pipeline or something that he anything
there you know pipeline that can even do
the gene annotation processors might be
a missed some point or anything like
that's why I would come forward thank
you very much for this question
so after performing any kind of analysis
aimed at identification of individual
differentially expressions they said to
or HR of something different there are
multiple options for gene set enrichment
analysis that it is one of the options
another option is for example gage well
so the number of tools is really huge
not only to but that it analysis should
be performed at their website which is
also very simple but alternative method
gage that also performs these the same
pathway or gene set enrichment analysis
just in using a different and more
complicated statistical model is
performed inside the the same platform
so it's performed inside the same
platform and it also provides us the
list of differentially alpha pathways
for example enriched by our
differentially expressed genes and also
of illustrations of genes of the map of
genes in this pathways that have this
differential expression for example
currently when we have a break let us
look at the progress we have here
so yeah probably you also have the same
output if you started the pipeline so
what is the result here generally just
to avoid downloading too many files of
the output in the platform for the gauge
gene set enrichment analysis are boots
into the into one archive inside this
archive what we'll have just a second
so is this archive I just unzip it
somewhere I unzip it somewhere so what
we have here first just similarly to the
output of that it for example and other
tools we have a set a list of analyzed
pathways so if we specified then the
list is a list of CAG metabolic and
signaling pathways then we have here all
metabolic and signaling pathways as the
main value we have here just similarly
to the adjusted p-value we saw in the
davits case is well theoretically Oh
statistically the same I mean also
adjusted p-value here it is called Q
value for each pathway so we see which
pathways have high level of enrichment
that is availability of observing the
same thing is low in case of no
enrichment and which pathways are not
involved in the process which pathways
do
have science of differences in
expression levels between the compared
groups again the standard thresholds is
0.05 it means that if adjusted p-value
is higher than these conventional
thresholds then generally its parts to
say that the pathway differs between the
compared groups and for all the groups
all the pathways with higher level of
differential expression in our case as
you remember we set the threshold equal
to 0.1 in parameters we also have a
visualization a standard visualization
so for example the most differentially
expressed pathways is related to focal
adhesion and has an identifier 0 4 5 1 0
so for this set and for all
sorry and for other different pathways
enriched by different expressions we
have a visualization we have a
visualization here so we simply find a
file with the required identifier and
see which players are involved in these
pathways and which players in these
pathways are done regulated so these
players are colored with green or art
regulated these players are colored with
red additionally these outputs contains
an R script that performed all the
analysis using the gauge module and this
R scripts can be naturally adopted for
other needs for example
the different visualization can be
performed so there's no need in
preparing an independent script that
performs this type of the analysis if
some additional informations required if
slightly different visualization is
required this our scripts can be simply
corrected and run in any machine
including Windows machine with our
studio Linux machine Oh sounds like this
so this adaptation simple adaptation can
be much faster in comparison with
preparing in you our scripts so rates
probably if the run no yeah there are
some great things
okay yeah fortunately as far as I see
thanks thanks thank you yeah sorry so
yeah now we're unmuted both unmuted so
I'll be glad at least to try to answer
one more question and then one more okay
again thanks for this very good question
from the formal point of view if we
analyze one sample the difference is
minor for each individual sample these
measures are proportional so there's
always a multiplier a constant that can
help us to go from fpkm to TPM and to
the opposite side but these constants
are different for different samples
there
well methodological difference between
these measures is the following if
became has no natural biological
interpretation we understand perfectly
well the reason of the definition so we
have to perform scaling by gene length
we have to perform scaling by the number
of reads just to reduce the influence of
these two types these two differences in
gene length and in sequence and depth on
the result but still if we have F became
equal for example to tell a hundred or
anything else
this value is hardly interpretable CPM
has a natural interpretation as it's a
number of transcripts per million so if
a CPM measure equals for example 100
Regine it means that if you randomly
select one million of transcripts 1
million of messenger RNA molecules in
your sample approximately 100 of these 1
million will be transcripts associated
with these genes
so in fact TPM gives us relative
expression level of each gene relative
with respect to the total expression
level to the total number of transcripts
in a sample so the methodological
difference is in interpretability
additionally there are some manuscripts
that say that TPM has a bit high
reproducibility in comparison with fpkm
so if we perform the same experiment for
example in terms of biological
replicates then repair for TPMS the
results will be more producible they
will be closer for different replicates
in comparison with F became but is just
the statement of a few manuscripts that
dealt with these measures so it's one of
the opinions but the opinion well
explains and explain with googled
argument as good experimental arguments
and number of manuscripts and number of
publications so great great so let's go
on further just in a minute and so as
we've got unsupervised and supervised
analysis for the discussion today and
hopefully more questions so two more one
or two minutes break and then we'll
proceed with the unsupervised
[Music]
okay so please let me know when we can
go on further I guess we are having fun
questions over the jack so come you can
start one minute
I guess we can go see what they're gonna
think oh great we can see great okay so
as we discussed for the differential
expression analysis we just please let
me know is the correct screen is on now
in the broadcasting if you see the
presentation just the title of what
yeah it's Factory and that's what be
going back now great great so let us go
on and let us imagine a situation when
initially we do not know the group's
inside our set of samples and it is a
very extended situation in case of
analysis of at least some pathologies at
least some diseases and as an example
today we'll use a set of cell breast
cancer associated cell lines
initially we know nothing about these
cell lines it may moreover I think that
many of us don't know details of this
pathology and so initially worthless
might think that all samples all in this
case cell lines associated with breast
cancer are somehow similar to the other
at the same
time for some pathologists different
subtypes exist and the existence of
subtypes allows optimizing through
practical different drug strategies for
the subclasses if patients are different
if patients can be divided into these
subclasses possibly different treatment
strategies are optimal for these
subclasses so what we initially have for
this analysis is raw quantification for
example in this case measured by log two
scales F becames
again for about fifty breast cancer
samples this data is stored in the main
file staff folder the file cell lines
expression data dot txt what we have
here is expression levels of
approximately 7,000 of genes 452 samples
we really use the number of genes
keeping allergies with sufficiently high
expression level just to slightly
improve the analysis speed but in any
case these analysis are fast so it's
very hard to analyze subgroups looking
at tables but there is a simple tool for
the analysis of existence of subgroups
called principal component analysis from
the mathematical point of view these
methods simply selects linear subspace
which optimally approximate approximates
our initial data for visualization the
standard dimension is simply 2 as
generally we have two dimensional plots
the idea
the idea behind the principle component
analysis can be informally described as
follows so imagine that we have an
object for example a pen and I have a 3d
pen but what you see is a simple 2d
plane to deplane projection of this pen
so if I select a pro plane a poor
projection a poor direction of the
project projection as for example I do
now you have almost no information about
an object but if I select a different
projection plane you see as much as
possible for this object you can easily
identify the object type you can easily
understand the object details so there
are more informative and less
informative planes with respect to the
projection of this plane so again here
you see almost nothing out of the object
here you see an object well much better
the same thing the same thing is related
to the analysis of samples which are
initially points in a space with number
of dimensions equal to the number of
analyzed features genes for example but
can be projected even on a 2d plane in
order to see the result of this
projection let us create one more very
simple pipeline so let us go to the
areas of analysis unsupervised analysis
has to provide analysis up
these files were talking about upload
the file were talking about the file
cell-lines explore data expression data
dot txt cell Lyons expression data dot
txt and having this file uploaded with
me again create a very simple very small
pipeline which includes only one module
for principal component analysis +
drawing the resulting plots again here
the default options are perfectly okay
with like the number of principal
components analyzed we select scale and
central parameters and transpose
argument tells which what goes by
collins and what goes by ruse samples or
fishes here again as I told the default
options are okay so we complete this
pipeline give it the name for example QC
test and run it so the pipeline is
really computational is simple so it
won't take long to have the result
so just for starting the process for
switching between start module main
model of the pipeline and the last model
it may take certain time well the time
won't be too long and we'll see the
result so initially as we discussed we
deal with samples associated with just
one pathology and so we may expect to
have one group of samples
with no clear differences between any
subsets so okay we'll have the result
soon but in order to save time let me
show you the resulting plot in the
screen now and then we'll see that the
pipeline result will be just this tape
he is the resulting plot and in this
plot we see perfectly well that samples
are separated in at least two groups
samples are separated in at least two
groups and interestingly for breast
cancer indeed
subtypes exist these subtypes in deeds
differ in optimal treatment strategies
and the authors of the manuscript which
provided the dataset who are using
annotated these samples using the
division into four subtypes luminal
basal Claussen low and normal like so
the number of subtypes is 4 but clearly
we see here only two groups if we look
at samples associated with each subtype
in this plot would have the plot you see
now we could see and we'll run this
pipelines very soon that one subtype
luminal is gathered to the left of our
figure and three other subtypes clothing
little basil normal like are grouped in
the right part of the figure of the
principal component plot so principal
comes in one versus principle component
two thus the difference between these
three type subtypes is much smaller than
the difference between these subtypes
and the luminal subtype so let us take a
look here indeed my pipeline is finished
hopefully yours is also completed and
what we have in the output again
additionally we have certain r script
with additional information that can be
used if a different visualization is
required or some different options are
desirable which cannot be selected where
the general platform interface but the
main output file is the PC plots dots
PDF so and in this file we see the plot
which I saw in the presentation and
additionally we can see the location of
samples in lot associated with other
principal components as we specified
number of analyzed principal components
equal to 3 will have all the plots with
comprehend Swan 2 and 3 so we'll also
have a plot for company 2 versus
component 3 so the question is whether
we can reduce the number of genes and
still have a very similar information
and have very similar information about
groups of samples about locations of
samples or it have even better
information about samples so we might
think that the reduction of the
considered number of genes is
not desirable as more data we have more
conclusions we can draw out of this data
however the majority of data we're
looking at now is a simple noise the
majority of genes potentially have no
interconnection with the question of
interest so reduce a number of genes can
potentially increase signal-to-noise
ratio as can potentially give us more
data more information more results in
comparison with the analysis of the
complete set of genes and indeed let us
look at what's happening if we reduce
our focus from 7,000 genes to just 15
specifically preselected specifically
preselected genes so let us construct
one more principal component analysis
plot let us go again to the section with
unsupervised analysis and this time
upload a file which contains information
only for 15 genes the last 15 genes
marked dot txt the file salons 15 genes
marked dot txt here it is and just
repeats creation of the same pipeline
just repeat creation of the same
pipeline we leave all the options in
their default values give a name to the
pipeline and start it
if we look inside the file we uploaded
to the system we see information just
for 15 genes and additionally for each
sample group is specified this
information is used by the plotting
module to show the location of each
group in the principal component
analysis plots so just samples
associated with the same group in our
case subtype of cancer will have the
same colors will have the same color so
this pipeline is also relatively forced
to let's just wait for 4 minutes and
we'll have the result of this pipeline
available my version and hopefully for
the ones who are also studying it indeed
does not take long
and while we're waiting let me again pay
your attention to the fact that
principle component analysis is a
powerful method but still the final
examination of results is performed well
intuitively is performed by a visual
inspection of resulting plots so we can
see certain separation in two clusters
we have our intuition to be used to see
the groups in this plots if initially we
know nothing about these groups so
principle component analysis is
primarily a tool for visualization but
not for clustering and clustering is a
task of dividing all the samples we have
in the subgroups in which similar
samples are grouped in one cluster and
dissimilar cell samples are generally
located in different clusters so again
my principle common analysis only 15
genes is finished again hopefully yours
are also finished and here let us take a
look at plots we have we see as we
discussed that the reduction genes
indeed improved our signal at least if
we discuss separation by subclasses just
automated analysis of these 15 genes
better separated subclasses but still as
you see here normal like samples and
basal samples at least look similar at
least have similar locations but he if
we see no colors we may see a different
number of clusters from
but personally for me in this figure I
see three clusters the left one the top
one and the bottom one in order to have
formal answer in the problem of
clustering in the problem of division of
samples into subgroups we can try to
utilize we can try to use a model that
specifically performs automated
clustering if there are again multiple
methods for automated clustering Oh
probably the simplest ones are
hierarchical clustering and k-means but
let us here our kicker clustering using
Jack as the same input data let us have
a look at one more pipeline let us
create one more pipeline in the same
section unsupervised analysis let us
upload the file cell lines 15 genes is
just it includes it contains it's fresh
levels for the same 15 genes but does
not contain marks labels of initial
classes and create a pipeline with one
model each class model that performs
hierarchical clustering here we might
want to change a number of parameters
the first let me set number of clusters
but if you like five more if like three
more please feel free to says other
values and let us also check that we'll
discuss the meaning of this parameter
shortly for example towards d2 so
linkage type was set toward d2 and
number of clusters were set to four so
that's it
so there since and while the pipeline is
running let me explain briefly what is
the logic behind here again your
plastering so our task is to divide
samples which am he represented by dots
into groups in such a way that similar
samples are grouped in the in the same
cluster and this similar or unknown
group the problem is that initially we
know nothing about the number of
clusters so we can use a button up
botton top strategy and start with a
situation with a state in which is
sample is a separate cluster then we
simply find two samples that are most
similar to each other and the similarity
is determined by the matrix the distance
function we specify and further on in
the procedure of button up here at
Hillcrest ring which reach this pair of
samples as one was a sample so these
samples are united into one by the
sample then we find the next pair of
samples of whether samples for which the
distance is the last one and unite them
and continue this process but in this
continuation we need to define the
distance not only between individual
samples but also between groups of
samples between our quasi samples
definitely there are very there are many
very different ways of defining distance
between sets of samples between who are
the samples it can be mean distance it
can be minimum minimum distance maximum
distance median distance various the
additions are possible here and this
linkage type parameter effect specifies
these this option of hiragana clustering
how to calculate the distance between
other samples but not individual samples
so this procedure is continued at each
stage number of groups is reduced by one
by uniting two groups into one and
finally at the end of this procedure we
have all samples united into one group
this visualization provides very little
information but but much more natural
visualization is standardly used for
hirako clustering so if we look at the
output of our pipeline again stored in
the Downloads pipeline output files we
see a PDF plot here we see a PDF plot
here in which samples are enumerated are
listed in the bottom and then links show
the order in which samples of whether
samples were United the height of the
link is a measure so the height of the
link shows the dissimilarity between
clusters while uniting so this figure
obviously shows that all our data can be
naturally divided into two clusters and
if we just cut this tree at the height
of for example 40 we have will have a
separation of all the samples into two
well-defined clusters but potentially we
further reduce our cut-off level and
have higher number of clusters so if we
reduce our cut-off level to Val for
example well 25 will have one group of
cluster and now the group of class I of
sample sorry one group of samples one
cluster and now the cluster another
group of samples and one more cluster so
the next reduction of heights
will further will further increase the
number of clusters and surprisingly just
a moment
best moment surprisingly in our case
these four clusters just perfectly
coincide with samples associated with
each subtype of breast cancer moreover
you see here that if we further reduce
the cutoff height will have the luminal
cluster divided into two subgroups and
indeed clinical data exists and in these
in standard classification of breast
cancer samples of breast cancer patients
in the subtypes luminal subtype is
further further subdivided into two
groups luminal a and little B so what we
see here in these simple examples we see
at least two texts the first fact is the
following even knowing nothing about a
existence of different subclasses
existence of different subgroups we can
identify
we can discover this existence this is a
probability into subgroups by
unsupervised analysis it can be
performed for example by a simple
application of principal component
analysis and visual inspection of plots
or by he request ring and again
inspection of diagrams which clearly
shows the number of evident clusters the
second fact we saw is that sometimes
having smaller information is more
efficient than having larger information
for example if we are looking at certain
treasures and have well thousands of
maps out of which only one or two has
the location out of these treasures
we'll have a lot of problems and we'll
have to spend a lot of time looking at
the required map and then looking at
treasures if we have much smaller number
of maps but these maps still include the
information we need our procedure for
finding will be more efficient the same
thing is here in analyzing genes if we
reduce the number of genes but
simultaneously increase an analogy of
signal-to-noise ratio then potentially
we'll have more information out of this
analysis then potentially we'll have a
much clearer figure of what's happening
definitely the problem is in the optimal
selection of these genes so currently
it's not clear how these 15 genes were
looking at were selected but they let me
tell you that were also selected
automatically so now initial biological
in fact now-now-now initial biological
insight was used for this selection in
many cases it is an iterative procedure
we perform clustering based on the
complete
of genes we seen that samples can be
divided into clusters and we select
genes that differentiate that clusters
as much as possible
for example using a conventional
differential expression analysis we
discussed in the first part of our
workshop then we limit our focus to this
much smaller set of genes clustering and
have slightly different
well optimally a bit better group of
samples as we focused on the genes
identified in a way as informative ones
so for this new groups for these new
clusters we repeat the analysis we
repeat the selection of potentially most
informative genes we then go back to
clustering and using these iterations we
potentially get better and better vision
get a better and better idea of clusters
we have in our data just to see that
there's indeed no technical difficulty
in these types of the analysis let us
try to test the skills using an another
example of the data so in the set of
files were all have there's a subfolder
called hands-on and in this hands-on
subfolder we have a table with
expressions for the simplicity we left
only the same 15 genes but the number of
samples here is relatively high we have
40 samples here and the structure of the
sample space is the following some
samples here originated from human
patients human patients with breast
cancer
and some samples were taken out of their
mice models so so-called patient drugs
and graft model in which humans humor is
implanted into a in turn a mouse and
then grooves fuller into the micro
environment related to Mouse clearly
micro environments for humans and mice
are essentially difference and obviously
samples originated from humans and mice
should be significantly different even
in spite of the fact that these samples
are all human humor samples and
represented the same pathology so the
test I want to discuss with you is the
following can we subdivide all these 40
samples into groups and to understand
which samples are grouped together as
potential human samples and which group
samples grouped together as potentially
my samples so we do not need to
hypothesize which group is a human group
and which group is a mice group but we
needs to try to divide these samples
into two groups humans versus mice
knowing nothing more about the biology
and about the clinical features behind
this data set so how can we go further
and how can we find this division so let
me give you just a few minutes for this
task obviously we do not have a lot of
tools here but I hope that you'll find
even the small set of tools we discussed
be sufficient for this hands-on tasks
though for example let us try to solve
this task in five or seven minutes and
then we'll discard the result
if there are any questions please feel
free to chat with us over the gorge a
box present on the website
okay so one option we can do here is
obvious
so in fact both are obvious we can do
either principal components analysis oh
here I get class string so let me try
just try to start here out of your class
ring while you're also try to perform
and try to test your own ideas I create
an unsupervised analysis pipeline
I simply upload the file I'm interested
in I simply take this file out of the
hands-on folder I used here a question
for example setting the same linkage
type and is with a as we expect two
clusters
I said cluster on a number of clusters
to two and simply run this pipeline
on which class for example
so hopefully if the sets are indeed very
different then we'll really have a clear
separation and while it runs I also
create our principle component analysis
pipeline with just the same file with
just the same file so principle
component analysis is for example with
the default options and let me then test
what will be in the plot
though here it is and so while waiting
for the results please as usual feel
free to ask questions well as we might
think that we currently have a short
break and after this break we'll
continue and have a very short but
hopefully informative discussion of the
superest statement of the analysis the
discussion that along with standard
differential expression analysis we can
also efficiently solve the problem of
classification the problem of
construction similar to the problem
solved by various gene signatures so if
you have questions please feel free to
ask me to ask any questions okay
okay so let me have a look let us all
have a look at the output we have after
the irregular class during pipeline so
first we can look just at the same den
haag ROM at the PDF file and indeed we
see the clear separation and the two
clusters the left cluster and the right
cluster if want to see the clustering
labels associated the class labels
associated with each sample for the
cutoff height
that leads to two clusters well we
simply we can simply look at the file
that's also contained in the output I'm
speaking about two clusters as while
riding the pipeline I specified the
estimated number of clusters equal to
two if I specify this number equal to
three
then I'll have cluster IDs for the
cutoff hate associated with the level
that leads to three clusters so here we
have for example file which name
includes cluster only suffix and if we
look if we look at the file
we'll see sample IDs and cluster IDs so
indeed here in this very simple case
with analysis we have perfect separation
all samples which identifiers finish
with even numbers our samples which
identifiers finish with even numbers are
yeah my samples as far as I remember
mice samples all samples which
identifiers finish with odd numbers
91-83 325 and so on are human samples so
here are clustering provided us this
division very easily moreover if we look
at this diagram we see that there's a
clear separation of the PDX of the mouse
originated samples into two groups and
indeed in this case all humans
impuls were taken from patients that had
the same subtype of breast cancer and
for the mice case two subtypes of cancer
were included into the analysis luminol
and basil and this division this
obviously sin division simply
corresponds to the division into this
liminal subtype and basal sub-site again
initially we'll you nothing about this
subdivision but the analysis shows us
this subdivision perfectly well for the
principal component analysis the result
can potentially be not so obvious for
the point of view of visualization but
let us see it's them here are the plots
here are the plots and again we see here
would potentially see here two groups of
samples left one and run one probably
the watering line the separation line is
a diagonal one so and indeed human
samples are located in one center plane
with respect to this intuitively seen
line and why samples allocated in the
earth plane having already understanding
of these division into subgroups a
natural question is to the following can
we attribute and you sample to one of
the subgroups for example for breast
cancer
our unsupervised analysis revealed the
presence of the subgroups we have
certain insights into the therapists
strategy at least we might have these
insights and we have a new patient the
question is whether we can associate
this new patient with one groups
with one subtype identified at our
previous stage identified at our
previous step and this is just a
standard problem statement for the
supervised analysis so the input data
here is a learning set which includes
samples with no label classes
so after unsupervised analysis after
some discussions and scientific research
some clinical research will already know
subclasses we already know subtypes and
we have sufficient number of samples we
have sufficient number of examples
associated with each subtype the
question is how to identify a subtype
for novel patient it can be done their
various supervised methods one of the
methods that can be simply described is
so-called sports vector machine so a
simple description here or not universal
one is the following
imagine that green circles and red
squares represent patients from two
different subtypes in our plane and
imagine that there's a perfect linear
probability if there's a perfectly nice
ability then there are many lies that
perfectly separate the sense and a
natural question is which line is an
optimal one which line is an optimal one
a natural also provided by what Mike and
Sharon Hankins in 60s and 70s is the the
birth the optimal line is the line which
provides the separation with as much
width of separating space as possible
when there is no perfect variability we
can introduce an optimized fast
functional as a mixture of the width of
this separating space and the penalty of
being located
into incorrect part of the plane or 3d
space if we have three features tone and
D space if we're working with and
features for example and jeans so in
this case penalty will be additionally
given for two red samples two green
samples and the balance between width
and penalty will be determined by the
parameter so heavenly learnings sets we
have this separating line again the
separation line is determined based on
the learning set and then if we have any
you sample we can look whether it looks
like a green sample like a sample from
one group or like a sample from another
group and to answer this question it's
sufficient to know this separation line
if a new sample lies in one semi plane
in assembly and associated with green
samples this sample is attributed to the
green group and in the other case this
sample is attributed to the red group
definitely is just one of the rough
examples there are many different types
for classifier construction many of them
are very dissimilar or random forced for
example but in any case the idea is that
having the learning set would try to
find the rule of attributing every new
sample with arbitrary features through
one of the classes and in our platform
there are multiple tools which all have
their peculiar features for example
Heretic discriminant analysis cannot be
applied the case for the number of
features is larger than the number of
samples or in other words when the
number of samples is insufficient in any
case there is always a choice at least
four methods can be applied even in case
of small number of samples another
question is this
say of this application to what example
can show us the application of these
methods we already have these breast
cancer cell lines divided into four
types and this information can be used
as an input for constructing for tuning
a classifier so we initially specify
which subtype is which sample is
attributed to which subtype so it is a
learning it is a learning set and we
have a set of new samples for which we
know nothing and we want to atribute
them to one subclass or to another
subclass in our in this case you see in
these files that data stored is just
identical but definitely it's not normal
for the real situation when we use a set
for learning and then wants to use the
same set for testing we want to apply
our classifiers to novel samples so to
make the situation more realistic let us
remove a number of samples from our
training set well for example as an
example let me remove the sample 600 MPE
from now training set if you try to
perform your own experiments you're
welcome and please feel free to remove
any others samples but I remember these
sample and I remember that it is luminal
and for example let me remove HCC 1143 a
basil sample and save the result and
save the result so this
samples two samples are removed from our
training centers there are no more
information related to these samples and
let me take only these two samples as
new ones so in the set of new samples I
leave I keep only the sample 600 in PE
and I keep the same poll I'm looking at
it here it is HCC 1143 so here's our new
ears all new test set and the system
indeed machine learning methods
supervised machine learning method knows
nothing about these samples so in order
to construct a classifier a function
which is able to deal with new samples
we need to use suppress analysis section
of the platform and the usage is quite
simple we upload we upload training set
we upload test set to work load two
files we need just two more minutes and
we'll see the results and that will be
finish and we select one of the machine
learning methods well as we discussed
there is Limina discriminant analysis
for example random for support vector
machine naive bias for example let it be
naive bias and complete the pipeline
test nice voice so this pipeline will
construct a classifier using only our
training set and then apply this
classifier don't use samples from our
test sets just similarly we can
construct a classifier we
uses completely different mathematical
model well let it be for example random
forest for deep analysis for deep
understanding of these mathematical
models essentially more time is required
for the discussion but again we upload
these files will tell the system to
construct a classifier using random
forest methods and this classifier will
be then automatically applied to our new
samples well pipelines are running let
me just summarize the main points of our
discussion we had today first in many
cases no coding skills no statistical
background and no mathematical
background is required for standard
processing of RNA sequencing data even
starting from raw data this procession
standardly includes processing that can
be avoided without an essential effect
but still adapter training is desirable
expression level quantification and in
many cases differential analysis can be
performed all this can be performed
using simple mouse interface in the tab
bar bar in the platform so for
differential express genes there are
multiple characteristics of differential
expression we can't look only at full
changes for example statistical
significance is important and Ghosh's
coefficient is important for genes with
low expression then having this list of
differential expressions we can perform
gene set enrichment analysis of pathway
enrichment analysis again it can be
performed without coding skills if we
deal with standard setting human gage
engage is one of the possibilities for
this analysis what having children
skills can help us to adopt the outputs
to adopt for example visualization to
our needs next if we deal with the
samples without knowing initially known
structures if we simply quantify
expression levels unsupervised analysis
methods can provide us these insights at
least can tell us whether all samples
comprise one group or can be natural
subdivided into groups into clusters
today we discussed only one approach to
clustering however multiple approaches
exists and then if we know groups if we
know which groups are associated with
the question of interest for example
with the pathology then we can and if we
have a learning set set of examples for
each subgroup we can construct
classifiers using supervised machine
learning analysis approaches and
attributes new samples to one group or
not for example we can look at the
results of the naive Bayes
classification see it's subclasses to
the test set so I look at files with the
test set suffix and I see that 600th MP
sample was classified as luminal and HTC
1143 was classified as Basel so indeed
the classifier that you nothing
initially about these samples classified
these samples correctly in a similar way
we can look at the results of red
the forest classifier again in the set
of output files will have a file with a
rest for desk set suffix and full random
forest classifier again we see that the
classification results are correct
definitely we can't expect these
automated methods to give perfect
results in all the cases but in simple
cases their performance is quite good so
overall we today we covered initial
procession of any sequence data
pre-processing expression level
quantification some conventional
approaches for differential expression
analysis and discuss the statements and
the ways of going through and supervised
and supervised analysis of samples aimed
at classification thank you very much
for attention and please feel free to
ask questions so let's try to see what
are these questions and you are welcome
to have your own experiment experiments
with all these datasets to test various
methods to compare them so this hands-on
experience you can probably have now and
definitely is able to have an future is
hopefully really good and really helpful
as here all the time we worked with real
data in the majority of cases the data
originated from the cell Lyons project
the breast cancer cell line project
that's it
thanks a lot everyone I'm together in
tango thanks Julia
thank Jack and Xavi and all the
participants for taking all the time for
this workshop we have our basic courses
on e tu t cache file or input and we
have this over exits you can try out and
play around different pipelines the
access is valid for 14 days from now if
you have any questions any doubts feel
free to reach out to the chat box or you
can email either one of us and if there
are any questions feel free to reach out
words and here